global national with donna friesen
[Music]
in ukraine's capitol tonight there is
great unease the sound of explosions and
air raid sirens
kiev is under attack airstrikes and
missiles targeting the city of 3 million
people ukraine's president who says the
international community has left his
people to fight alone posted this video
with his top staff saying they will stay
in kiev despite the risks
ukrainian officials say they've handed
out 18 000 assault rifles to volunteers
and russia's president called on
ukrainian forces to put down their
weapons and turn on their government
nato is preparing a combat ready rapid
defense force and has deployed more
troops not to send to ukraine but to
nato countries nearby these are british
forces in estonia
peace on our continent has been
shattered
we will defend and protect
every ally against any attack and every
inch of nato territory
british defense intelligence released
this map showing how far russian forces
have advanced into ukraine from the
north east and south and reveals how
they are closing in on the center of the
capital though facing stiff resistance
from the ukrainian army today prime
minister justin trudeau announced new
sanctions targeting the russian
president his chief of staff and
russia's foreign minister and trudeau
says canada supports removing russia
from the swift banking system
he cannot expect to
overturn
and end 75 years of peace with a violent
and unprovoked attack on an innocent
neighbor
and still expect to be able to benefit
from the financial systems and economic
opportunities
that that very peace has created over
the past 75 years
good evening and thanks for joining us
late today ukraine's president said the
fate of the country is being decided
right now that it will be a very hard
night we begin our coverage in kiev
associated press reporter joe fetterman
is there joe you're talking to us from
the central part of the city near the
shelter of your building where you're
staying it's another anxious night for
people there what are you hearing and
seeing
yeah it's been anxious uh almost around
the clock uh our day began at about four
in the morning with air raid sirens uh
and we have spent uh the entire day
going up and down the stairs into the
basement
seeking shelter i've lost count how many
air raid sirens we've experienced today
and in many cases shortly after you hear
the sirens you hear explosions in the
background
the explosions earlier in the day and
yesterday were far off in the distance
in this evening just in the past couple
of hours you hear the explosions much
closer much louder much more intense so
the sense is that uh the russian forces
are closing in on us yeah well we've
heard that from others as well that the
russians are advancing towards the city
center what are you hearing about
ukrainian resistance both from the army
and from conscripts who have been given
guns
yeah the resistance seems to be taking
place more in pockets i think it's
become very clear over the past 24 hours
that uh ukraine is heavily outgunned by
the russians we knew this we were
expecting some sort of resistance but
the russians have been moving in very
quickly so what you hear are about sort
of isolated incidents where the
ukrainians put up resistance in one
place or another
you hear about these sort of citizen
people buying guns and getting very
basic paramilitary training or whatever
but the overall trend is that they are
heavily outgunned and the russians are
moving in on them
you know the country's president pleaded
for the world uh to the world for more
help what is the mood among people there
about the international reaction
yeah you uh you know we were speaking uh
to uh some university students today and
they were talking about this and i think
the way i would describe it uh you know
they do not somebody was asking me if
they feel uh if ukraine feels abandoned
by the outside world and i wouldn't go
that far i think the the key word here
is disappointment uh they appreciate the
backing they appreciate the
condemnations the backing at the u.n the
financial aid uh the the sanctions on
russia they appreciate all of that stuff
but they want more and what they want is
military aid they want the world to
really come to their defense and they
don't see that happening all right joe
fetterman from associated press in kiev
tonight thank you thank you
russia's war in ukraine has provoked a
refugee crisis thousands are fleeing the
russian assault and heading for
neighboring countries including poland
that's where our crystal command singh
is tonight crystal
donna it is very busy here at the shema
shield train station which has been
turned into a red cross site now some of
the people who have arrived here have
been on a journey that has been taken
almost an entire day they are tired but
they are all telling us that they are
grateful to be safe but they know their
family members back home simply aren't
the kremlin is looking to squeeze the
life from ukraine by capturing its roots
kiev
the russian invasion now laying siege to
the capital and those of the nearly 4
million residents who are left
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says civilian sites are being targeted
and innocent people are being killed
apartments and homes devastated by
rocket attacks still many ukrainians are
standing their ground fighting for their
homeland despite being outnumbered and
outgunned including zolensky showing
himself in the streets of keith amidst
false reports he had fled
premier minister
here we are says a defiant zelinski on
the streets of kiev his message the
citizens are here and we are here we
defend our independence zolensky may now
be putin's priority target seeking to
destabilize ukraine from the top down
the president also urging the world to
act and add tougher sanctions against
russia right now he and others say
ukraine is alone
underground people seek shelter hiding
even sleeping in metro stations built to
withstand cold war attacks others have
chosen to run
the united nations estimates more than
50 000 ukrainians have already sought
safety elsewhere the majority in moldova
and poland some border crossings are now
lined with vehicles others with families
fleeing on foot in the cold
this young woman says it took her nearly
24 hours to get to poland i really don't
know what to do i can pray god
to save
our hospitals and the trash will stop
bomb ukraine and hope my
best
my
native
people will be safe and i can
meet them again
others have tried to leave on trains
the scene becoming so frantic at times
guards fired rounds into the air to
regain control of frantic crowds many
have no choice but to stay put and hope
even as russia continues to advance
that they'll be okay
the longer this war goes on the more
people will flee and seek safety in
places like poland and that will mean
the more services will be needed for now
there is a lot of effort a lot of help
but no one knows how long this will all
last donna all right crystal in poland
tonight thanks for the first time in its
history nato is activating a rapid
response force and deploying it to nato
countries
neighboring ukraine it says it's
preparing should vladimir putin decide
to extend his invasion beyond ukraine
and ukraine's plea for tougher sanctions
against putin and russian interests were
met at least in part today jackson
proskow reports
in this perilous moment nato is on edge
the kremlin's objectives are not limited
to ukraine the sobering view of russia's
intentions prompted an urgent meeting of
the alliance and activation of a rapid
response force including an elite high
readiness unit
finland and sweden were invited to the
security meeting in defiance of vladimir
putin members promised military and
humanitarian aid to ukraine including
anti-aircraft systems and weapons they
can only hope it's not too late we are
sending a very clear message to to
russia
that we provide support to our
partner
ukraine attention
fears of a broader conflict in europe
have already prompted nato to bolster
its numbers along the eastern flank with
russia
in latvia american troops arrived as
further deterrence joining a canadian
unit already stationed there the taser
our allies starting from canadians and
ending with other europeans are with us
is a good signal that putin don't mess
with us the international pressure
campaign extends directly to putin
himself a move to disconnect russia from
the swift global banking network has
growing support and personal sanctions
are being levied against the russian
president and russia's foreign minister
by western governments including the us
and the eu the
only leaders in the world we are
sanctioned by the european union
assad from syria lukashenko from belarus
are now putting
from russia
there are still limits on how far the
west will go to defend ukraine nato
allies are firm they will not engage in
direct combat unless attacked there's no
talk of establishing a no-fly zone
despite requests from ukrainian
officials and none of the actions
announced so far have succeeded in
stopping the russian invasion or
convincing vladimir putin to back down
jackson prosko global news
washington canada's foreign affairs
minister says the sanctions canada
announced today against putin and those
close to him are designed to suffocate
the russian regime it's one of three
approaches the canadian government is
taking to support ukraine our chief
political correspondent david aiken is
tracking the details of this david yeah
well donna let's start first with the
military canada is going to put an
artillery battery in latvia we'll deploy
two naval frigates a surveillance
aircraft a cyber warfare team and up to
460 new soldiers all under nato command
somewhere in eastern europe
allies are all
resolved and resolute that we are there
to protect europe's eastern eastern
flank to demonstrate that the alliance
is strong and ready to respond
but it will be at least a month before
much of that is in place donna and david
what about sanctions who and what is
canada targeting this is a pretty big
list and it now includes vladimir putin
himself 32 members of putin's inner
circle and russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov and all 351 members of the
russian parliament that voted to
recognize the independence of those
eastern regions of ukraine 27 key
financial institutions four ukrainians
that canada has identified as
pro-russian agents of disinformation and
today 57 people in belarus the world
has responded in an unprecedentedly
united
and coordinated way
to respond to vladimir putin's
grave mistake
canada also supports russia being
removed from swift that is the global
financial network used by international
banks and kicking russia off of swift
will swift will make it very difficult
for any russian entity to engage in any
kind of international financial
transaction donna
all right and david we should point out
that hasn't happened yet but david what
is canada doing to help ukrainians who
want to leave their country
well the government has put in place a
number of measures to rapidly issue
visas even for those without a passport
processing fees are being waived more
consular staff is being assigned to the
region and the government says
ukrainians already here in canada who
have work or study permits that are
expiring can have them extended that
said ukraine is now forbidding any male
from 18 to 60 years of age from leaving
the country because ukraine needs all
the manpower it can get so it's unclear
just how many refugees we will see here
donna
all right david in ottawa thank you
coming up how ukraine is gearing up for
a long battle
[Music]
russians saying no to war they continue
to defy their president risking arrest
to protest the war in ukraine protests
like this are illegal in russia
and political opposition leaders are
either poisoned or in jail at least 1700
people were arrested in the protests on
thursday
well the quest keeps saying vladimir
putin will pay a price for this invasion
sanctions will take time though to take
hold and have a real economic impact
that means putin needs a victory fast
eric sorenson has been talking to
experts about what russia's next moves
might be it is a full-scale war that
many experts just didn't believe russia
would start president vladimir putin in
one fell swoop demonstrated his
country's military might and instantly
isolated russia from much of the world
like a lot of people we
had concluded that a full-scale invasion
of ukraine
was
was irrational this former canadian
ambassador to russia says the costs are
too great retaliation on russians
banking travel and economy and the
lasting harm to the country's stature
the array of
sanctions will increasingly i think
isolate them as something of a pariah
state internationally at a minimum then
putin needs a swift military victory
it's pretty clear that he wants the
whole country it looks like occupation
and annexation are the objectives but in
recent years ukraine has built up its
military and its resolve ukrainians seem
prepared for a prolonged conflict with
ongoing guerrilla tactics if necessary
the ukrainian government will want to
put as much
resistance as they can to make the costs
of invasion as high as possible why
would putin risk it russia's neighbor
does not threaten it militarily but it's
hard to ignore that ukraine is becoming
a model of progress right next door to
russia's authoritarianism every day
ukraine is becoming a bit more
democratic
a bit more prosperous so this is very
much about
undoing a possible um a possible
alternative that is becoming a real
existential threat to him and his
kleptocratic regime there's already
discontent among russians tennis star
andre rublev wrote no war please on a tv
camera lens and remember how popular
alexander ovechkin was with vladimir
putin maybe not after ovi sent out this
message others are willing to be
arrested for protesting and the war has
only just begun russians will not be
happy with body bags
of their sons coming back to russia
so i i don't think this will be a
popular war experts didn't see how war
could advance russia's interests and
believe vladimir putin may realize that
soon enough eric sorensen global news
toronto
ahead war and oil prices soar what's the
connection to the conflict
russia is the third largest exporter of
crude oil and the invasion of ukraine
has led to a spike in crude prices a u.s
state department official said today the
u.s will not sanction russian crude oil
because that would harm american
consumers and not vladimir putin heather
urix west explains the connection
between conflict and
oil this is not a war over oil but make
no mistake russia's energy exports
represent considerable leverage the
reality is that mr putin has played the
world
democracies
and free markets like a fiddle and for
many in many respects
we've not only bought into it we created
this the situation that's because when
it comes to oil the global energy market
is already incredibly tight with demand
only just starting to keep pace with
supply and as one of the world's biggest
oil producers russia accounts for just
over 10 percent of oil globally so even
if we lose you know 10
of russia's production these prices
could you know easily go up to 140 150
it's why western countries have
hesitated to impose sanctions against
russian energy exports so how did it
come to this the market generally right
now is very short
oil
ever since clovid and even before there
has been
not enough investment happening to keep
up with demand
canada of course has oil alberta sits on
the third largest reserve in the world
but the industry is still without viable
means to get that product to world
markets keystone was cancelled and the
trans mountain pipeline expansion
doesn't come online until at least late
next year if we had a willing federal
partner
and
a realistic u.s energy security policy
we could completely displace
u.s russian oil imports global reliance
on oil already threatens the climate now
it's a factor in the western response to
war in ukraine and russia's escalating
security threat as well
heather urex west global news calgary
how far would you go to defend your
country next the ukrainians who are
resisting the invasion
what's happening in ukraine a democracy
attacked by its nuclear-powered neighbor
is giving lots of people pause for
thought about what they would do how far
they would go to defend their
independence and resist the russians
despite the seemingly impossible odds
many ukrainians are unwilling to step
aside
as the sounds of war overrun ukraine and
people run for cover
in a country where men are being told to
fight
these sounds are hard to bear
here a man can hardly break away from
his daughter and his partner
for those who remain there are deep
signs of defiance
people who are unwilling to yield
this woman confronted heavily armed
russian soldiers you are occupiers and
fascists she says take these seeds and
put them in your pockets
at least she says sunflowers will grow
when you die here
the sunflower is ukraine's national
flower
and on this rocky island in the black
sea the same will to resist
a russian warship blared an ultimatum at
a small team of ukrainian border guards
lay down your arms and surrender they
said otherwise you'll be bombed
their response
russian warship
go f yourself
across the country people are choosing
to fight rather than flee
this apartment block in keeve took a
direct hit
inside oksana golenko was thrown across
her bedroom yes paula i was completely
confused she says i heard screams sounds
i got up and saw all the windows smashed
she and her daughter are now picking up
the pieces
and under her breath she's singing
ukraine's national anthem
long live ukraine she says
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen we leave you
with songs and signs of solidarity with
ukraine across canada
landmarks are being lit up in the colors
of ukraine's flag canadians can also
donate to help the federal government is
matching donations to the canadian red
cross ukraine humanitarian crisis appeal
dollar for dollar to a maximum of 10
million dollars
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves
[Music]
[Music]